Bitcoin down Twitter below 20 000 we
have a slew of uh crypto CEOs that are
resigning those are the signals right
now
it feels pretty bad
why are you bullish what are the bullish
signs that you're seeing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Kevin you fund
the the architecture right now and one
of your peers
uh Jamie dimon really continued to beat
down on it he said very recently
uh that Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies are nothing but a
decentralized Ponzi scheme yep so
um let me qualify my statements on this
because it's it's uh I'm an investor in
JP Morgan as well I have a lot of
respect for him he may be one of the
most successful banking managers in the
history of that sector however that was
an uninformed statement and it was not
helpful at a time when we're trying to
drive regulation through two different
bills on the hill right now I I along
with many other private investors have
been spending a lot of time in
Washington on this
um
essentially what Jamie said there he was
talking his book
this is my interpretation
he feels threatened by some of this
technology particularly around Payment
Systems because Banks make money
transferring assets
it's a cost of friction in the system
and one of the only reasons that I
invested in circle
and I'm an investor in circle I'm
supporting their initiative and I'm a
big believer in what stable coins can do
is it's time to get rid of that friction
and it's not important that Banks be
protected so they can make fees from
that friction when you transfer the US
dollar into the Swiss franc to buy
Nestle on the Zurich Exchange
these Banks add zero value there's no
value created in ACH transfer fees
if we could use a stable coin that was
regulated and approved by both sides of
that transaction it would be more
transparent it would be much faster it
would definitely be more productive but
above all
I would save millions of dollars and so
would everybody else I can't wait till
we can do that because that kind of
innovation should be supported and it is
and that's why we're all here this isn't
about you know
speculation on asset price this is about
reducing the fees of how the world's
economies work more transparent more
productive completely auditable
regulated but less expensive so does
Jamie Diamond feel threatened you're
damn right he does
that's a big part of how he makes money
too bad
[Applause]
for the 1.4 billion people who remain
unbanked uh out of Asia when we report
on blockchain crypto and web 3 we see
the fastest adoption of crypto in
countries like the Philippines where
they have 70 percent of adults that
remain unbanked these are not JPMorgan
clients right these are people who are
transferring their dollars back to
Philippines with remittances up to 17
percent this is this is what usdc stable
coins crypto can potentially unleash
yeah I I there is a social Mission here
that is a good thing but
it is not going to solve a different
problem we have right now the reason
we're stuck in a very low momentum state
in crypto and blockchain right now is
the lack of Regulation that keeps the
Institutional Investor out of this space
for all the excitement about stable
coins and Bitcoin and all the projects
and ethereum on down and polygon and
Miss then and everything that's coming
the truth is that none of it is owned by
institutions zero and so everybody likes
to say yeah yeah that's not you know but
Sovereign wealth and pension that I
service in the indexing business and
there's many people do what I do we
create indices so that they can invest
Capital they are waiting for regulation
before they index and so if if all that
happened was
Sovereign wealth funds put one to three
percent into maybe six different
projects it would definitely be some
Bitcoin there'd probably be some
ethereum there maybe some polygon maybe
a little Solana whatever they want to do
and what indexers would do for them
based on market capitalization
that's a trillion dollars worth of
demand but it none of it is going to
happen until we get some policy and the
truth about this is and I'm happy to
just say it the way it is
there are countries that are Advanced
there are places like Canada where they
allow broker dealers now attached to
accounts and Canadians can do that
they've got millions of accounts open
now
the UAE Switzerland France but the real
money The Sovereign wealth capital is
never going to move against the SEC
never going to happen and the reason
that occurs is that if you're a
sovereign wealth fund or a country
that's oil Rich perhaps you're
generating a quarter of a billion
dollars every 12 hours the only place on
Earth you can put that is in the s p the
only way you can do that is be being
compliant with the SEC rules they are
never going to make a move against the
SEC in any way until these rules have
been determined so we are being kept out
of institutional capital and Bitcoin is
not going to trade above 22 000 until we
get policy
interestingly enough and this is a
personal speculation if this
stablecoin transparency bill was passed
first before the digital Commodities act
which is the other big initiative right
now
and Jeremy wherever he is was the guy
that got that done
it be like bringing Led Zeppelin back
and he would be the lead singer because
if that happens
and if if it happens I speculate that
all assets all crypto assets would
appreciate overnight by 10 because it
would signal the move for policy so we
should all support the initiative of
everybody you know and and there there's
other people involved in this you shout
out to Sheila Warren and Perry Ann
boring who spent countless hours
educating legislators on the hill their
their missions are important
um but there's a lack of knowledge with
with the government that has we have to
get over this hurdle so
even if just stable coins that one thing
got policy and remember when I go up
there I keep telling these guys it's
just software
it's productivity software it's not
scary if you buy Microsoft for your
office and you're typing on word that
software that's a productivity tool a
stable coin is just software that allows
for more productivity and transfer of
assets at a much lower cost much more
productively let's be candid though that
race to want to figure out stablecoin
regulatory Clarity came after Tara Luna
crashed in May wiped out 60 billion
dollars and really created a lot of
distrust in the market when you need
people the mass the regular folks who
are actually using stable coins in ways
that we can only imagine here in the
United States this is a very mature
Market we are all well served in this
developed Market but the rest of the
world really needs these tools yeah but
how do they trust it sure so I think the
better way to look at this I think is
the lunar crash the other companies that
were lenders that went bankrupt
in a way you should look at that
optimistically because what's happening
here in this last nine months is we're
scraping the patina
and we're removing the idiot management
teams out of the market
all these these bankrupt ideas will not
come back because they were tested they
didn't work and that's an important way
to build an Asian industry so
it's the the litigators will litigate
over the assets and the lawyers will sue
everybody and that's that's okay because
now the remaining players are being
strengthened by the fact they're still
in business they're able to raise
Capital to the extent they're doing that
and
the idiots are gone what's wrong with
that and I think we start now even
though we're in a crypto winter at a
much better place and I think the fact
that they even woke Regulators up you
know when you lose 60 billion dollars
mind it was decentralized so a lot of it
was outside of the U.S
um
that's maybe good that's a good idea
look it's you got to feel sorry for the
the Pioneers that got the arrows in the
back but they were idiots so that's okay
too it's a good thing when The
Regulators are waking up and they're
talking to you they're talking to folks
like Sheila Warren over at CCI Perry and
boring
um over at digital Commerce uh Chamber
of Commerce all of these folks and yet
there's a stall are we going to see
movement before November 8th that's the
question we're all waiting
what's the best well I I think it's um
you know it's a great question and and I
and I asked the same question to I think
those women are in different places I
mean uh Parian is more negative than
Sheila I saw them both within an hour of
each other and I got two different
stories so it's and they're they're the
closest to it in the sense that they
spend so much time
we had an opportunity 48 hours ago to
have the bill go to markup I'm talking
about the uh stablecoin transparency act
it didn't
that's negative
uh I know Jeremy is optimistic that it
can get there in October I hope he's
right
um we have a bit of a distraction
midnight November 8th we don't know if
the house will flip or what's going to
happen with the Senate it's a coin toss
maybe this policy has to has to happen
after the midterms but
the whole investment premise of
of investing now is that you feel and
I'm now speaking you know categorically
I've put Money In Harm's Way in crypto
across now almost 50 projects and and
continuing to do so every week because
I'm in the camp that says in the next 12
months
something's going to break on policy I
think it's going to be the stable coin
transparency ACT first but that in
itself should open the floodgates
because if you if you ask a big let's
just take a big Middle Eastern Bank and
have to name the names but they've got
five million accounts with over 2
million dollars in each one and they
want to just have access to a stable
coin Bitcoin and one chain and they want
to offer that to their clients
they won't do that until there's
regulation there's no compliance
infrastructure at the moment and they
are getting ready for that to happen now
if all of a sudden stable coins the
backed by U.S dollar were made were
regulated entities
that would open up within 90 days and so
as an investor I say to myself do I
position myself now or do I wait for the
regulation because when
in a nascent industry and I happen to
believe and I've said this multiple
times this sector will be the 12th
sector of the s p in 10 years it will be
as an indexer I put up to 20 in a sector
so just like I would in energy or just
like I would in in Tech so
why not position myself now I'm not
going to get it right it's volatile as
hell
and some of the stuff I've invested is
going to zero but not all of it
and so
I think I'll do quite well
Kevin you're one of the smartest
contrarians I know
and when you take a look at the market
and you see everybody tacking left you
go right a little bit
right now everybody's talking left
Bitcoin down below 20 000 we have a slew
of uh crypto CEOs that are resigning we
have consolidation in the market Sam
bankman freed saving like the the you
know the the JP Morgan of of uh of the
21st century and and saving Voyager and
potentially Celsius uh Rumor Has It
those are the signals right now
it feels pretty bad
why are you bullish what are the bullish
signs that you're seeing
I've seen this movie before
um the time to be putting Capital to
work is when there's blood rushing
through the streets and that's happening
in crypto right now all of these uh
bankruptcies defaults changes in
management
it's a cleansing that's going on
it's a very difficult time to fund new
projects and any valuations that people
thought they were going to get four
months ago are being cut in half
sometimes down 60 percent
but the good ideas and the way to look
at this in my view and I'm you know I'm
fortunate I spent a lot of time teaching
graduating cohorts of Engineers uh you
know MIT Waterloo Temple wherever they
they are Harvard Business School guys
when you meet
those cohorts a third of the class
are entrepreneurial and so I'm doing
this selfishly I like to see their
projects before the VCS do so I'm
sitting in the class and we go out for a
beer afterwards whatever
here's what I've come through I've come
to this realization
if you ask them where they want to work
these are the brightest men and women on
earth to get into MIT you basically need
a perfect math score they don't care
what country you were born in you you've
got to be the best of the best and some
of those dudes are very eclectic people
I have to tell you
but
they don't want to work in manufacturing
anymore they don't want to work in the
existing 11 sectors of the s p they want
to work on the chain
they believe that the biggest
opportunity for them personally is to
work in this nascent space
that you know and the analogy would be
back at the beginning of the internet
when only pornography was streamed that
was it
we're at that stage now and so my
argument is to any investor
you can't pour that much intellectual
Capital into a space and not expect
extraordinary outcomes because those are
the people that are going to redefine
Industries using this technology I
believe that and I invest in them and
that's why it's good to put money to
work now because every day another
cohort comes out
remarkably we're doing some pretty
stupid things we're throwing them out of
the country they should stay here but
they go and work in the Caribbean
islands of the United Arab Emirates
wherever they can go to they're the best
of the greatest and the best and we kick
them out that's not since a different
problem but
the investment thesis is you go where
the intellectual capital is going
that's why a 20 allocation to crypto at
this point at these prices is a very
good idea
Pantera is Raising one in a quarter to
half billion for a new fund uh FTX is uh
putting Capital to work
you're putting Capital to work with some
middle aged Partners can you break some
news for us yeah I I we were together
just I always want to break some news
yeah I mean it is a bit I hadn't
announced this yet but I recently became
an emirati citizen I'm very proud of
that
um that's a very enlightened part of the
world uh 50 percent of the management
there are women I'm a huge supporter of
women entrepreneurs they're very
Advanced on their thoughts on crypto
particularly Abu Dhabi the adgm in order
to to work freely there it's better to
go through the scrutiny of citizenship
which is a
heavy scrutiny if you've had anything
that didn't work out in your past
they're going to find it but the point
is I've gone through that that Gauntlet
for one specific reason I'm also
launching a new fund it's called Cipher
it's only web3 my lead investor is is
from the United Arab Emirates there's a
tremendous amount of capital and
interest there
to invest in this space
um
and you know
in in managing the decisions on which
projects to to invest in because I'm
very fortunate my deal flow is insane I
see everything and I have to disclose
I'm a paid spokesperson to uh to FTX and
a shareholder there too because we
mentioned them and big advocate for Sam
because he has two parents that are
compliance lawyers if there's ever a
place I could be that I'm not going to
get in trouble it's going to be at FTX
so you know that's
they're great people but he gets the
joke on compliance which is why he's
working so hard to get regulation but
having said that
um
picking those projects is really an
interesting job because I look for
utility I'm looking for I think Jeremy
mentioned in his keynote we've got to
get away from the speculative price of
an asset here we've got to find reasons
that this it gets embedded into the
economy and so I'm interested in
solutions to you know how do we make a
blockchain that can actually transact
currency you know I'm very optimistic
about what we've said about ethereum but
I'm sorry it's still too slow and it you
couldn't do you couldn't work within the
the currency Market with that it's just
too slow how do you flip the switch most
of the headlines remain very speculative
um focused on that how what is the
utility that you're seeing today you're
willing to place money bets on
you know
um
I think we're at a phase now where we
stalled out I talked about the price of
Bitcoin it's not it's not going to go
over 22 000 until we have regulation
there's just no Capital to to move it
it's going to be stuck in this trading
range 18 to 22 for two years until
whatever the Commodities acts get gets
done or whatever and you have to realize
that now I will say there's Capital
still going into Bitcoin miners because
they're getting awarded coin at seven to
eight thousand if they have scale so
it's still profitable but nobody will
fund the early miners that used
carbon-based electricity so those guys
are screwed it's too bad but the new
projects are ones that are using
hydroelectric in places like Norway or
solar or
um so there's still there's still places
for Capital to go to work
but there's a pause
for policy and and it's never has the
anticipation been higher than it is now
everybody is getting bored with the
status quo and the U.S has to wake up
and get its poo poo together and start
regulating this stuff so I'm I'm not in
the camp that says we need to to place a
you know the original founders of crypto
and decentralize and let's fight the
government screw all that that we know
we know that that's not going to work
and we know that no one's going to make
any money if that's the case that's a
bad outcome the better outcome is
regulate the applications on the change
that should be regulated the policy
exists for some of it put policy out on
stable coins first I hope that we
consider Bitcoin and other token-based
opportunities Commodities if there's you
know if we're going to fractionalize
nfts maybe their security says all this
stuff but right now what we have is turf
wars
turf wars between The Regulators openly
declaring turf wars with each other
right this morning on CNBC
no it's my domain no it's my domain of
course they want to control it but at
some point the role of
the hill in Congress is to decide make a
decision it won't be perfect in the case
of stable coins right now what's what
held up that bill with the States
they're not happy well tough we got to
get this thing done and we got to move
on and and you know we can tweak it but
it's very frustrating at this point and
I think I I speak for a lot of people
the same way from the institutional side
it's time to get our act together we're
going to keep losing Talent people are
going to go work
you know on some Caribbean island
not where they should be in you know in
in the United States this is very
important stuff and we shouldn't be
losing our talent because we can't
regulate it that sounds dumb if you like
that video wait till you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe